I saw a line from one of your books that
said everywhere you go to ask an
economic question you get a climate
change answer can you say a little bit
more about that yeah so my my my last
book had one chapter out of ten about
climate change and and the more the more
into Europe you go the more people say
why aren't there nine chapters and
absolutely right it is the existential
problem even not more now since 2002 or
2018 since the IPCC report the urgency
is much more real we need to sort we
need to decarbonize the world it's
substantially by 2030 okay to - if David
Attenborough knows what the problems are
and what the solutions are I don't need
to write a book about it you see all I
mean I want to write a book about the
thing that people are not realizing and
that's why I've Bacchus so heavily on
questions of of human nature of human
agency and the threat to it but the
political programme I have is one of
where we combine the urgent need to
solve the problems of market economy
because if we can throw money into these
poor communities such as the one I come
from Lee in Lancashire 65% leave voting
biggest problem domestic violence zero
us contracts seven pound on our wages
that's it
as the life in Lee shops there's more
shops in independent shops in hay than
there are in lay a bigger town if we're
gonna if we could throw some resource
and money at them and change the
economic model in a way that becomes
much more human focused breaking up big
cheque providing new models of platform
cooperatives and Mutual's and nonprofits
and wiki style businesses I think we can
we can take those populations on the
journey they need to go on because the
nerd journey leading to go on is the
rapid transition beyond carbon and and
right now some of them are on the
reverse journey you know the brakes
apartheid only act to political here but
the brexit party is full of people from
the fossil industry
and climate deniers and fine because I
will have a I don't want to slide off
climate denies I want to like with the
man on the street I want to actually
debate them over the over the the actual
evidence but it's quite possible they
can't labor candidates in East London
what they terrified on London just
imposed a client a new climate levy on
on diesel vans to be fair a lot of quite
poor and quite precarious mail on
self-employed people who live right out
in in Essex and you know kind of places
like that east of limit are terrified
you know they are they are outraged at
the this new levy they say well I was it
what am I supposed to do you know my job
is white van man and and yet no this is
a tax on white van man to save the
planet well you screw that we need a way
of taking them with us and I think we
need a narrative that is strong towards
the goal so so that's how my ideas here
fit into the the piece that its climate
change I'm not a climate scientist I
haven't focused overwhelmingly on
climate in my career or the people who
are more expert than me can make that
case and I will support them my bit of
this project is to create a Progressive
Alliance of people that can have the
arguments and create that the narrative
that takes those communities where they
need to go yeah on algorithms in our
mind for want of a better catchphrase
and my three top tips would be for us to
retain an own our own data yep for us to
embed more mindfulness and meditation
and awareness into our society and
cultures and particularly children what
would be your two or three takeaways for
how we can actually address the issue so
in the book what I argue is that again
following Asda McIntyre but if you let's
say this four schools of it were moral
philosophy this there's Aristotelian
virtue ethics there's a Nietzsche [ __ ]
you just shoot people in the face and
laugh about it and anybody thinks he
doesn't say that you know that's that's
there but the two most popular ones in
the two most popular ones are you are
utilitarianism and and and social
justice
you know they ontological
ethical lists but MacIntyre argues
really that in our era
it's the its nature versus Aristotle and
so for me I buy that I buy the idea that
what we need is a virtue ethics a
concept of the eudaimonic life and
community in society at the level of the
whole human race and a concept of a new
set of virtues Foucault wrote seven a
piss-take of simple answers of sales
trucco wrote a seven seven bullet point
list of virtues for the postmodern era I
I want to move away from them I want I
want us to to reek and I think everybody
just does it themselves ask yourself
what is virtuous at a time when fascism
is is coming well we have good good role
models in the anti-fascist generation
and Frank all well levy ha Arendt
herself so to buy cheap is I wouldn't
want it have a conversation with
yourself and your peers about what is
what is what kind of person is needed to
create the good society and I think
that's the conversation that
neoliberalism eradicated I mean in the
neoliberal era we spent a lot of time
performing two criteria so how many
lesbians engaged are we employing in
this company a lot tick black people
tick women on the board tick we've given
to you know we've staged a cleanup of a
local beach tick there was no tick box
for and I believe it all and as a result
we find out that a lot of people are
sitting there ticking the box ago a
really believing that black people are
subordinate to white people that women
you know they're all alpha male beta
male women thing among the American
far-right is frightening that women
should you be alphas should get pretty
girlfriends beetus should get everybody
else and women should put up with it
that's that if you have a teenager on an
Xbox or a Playstation and they use the
voice channels to play the games ask
them if they've ever heard that said to
them you'd be very surprised that they
all have that's the theory that it's the
glue that sticks together the new far
right so so my answer to you is it's to
have a conversation about virtue
unpopular though
is in some social science department
thank you very much your talk very good
I think what if I can take from it if I
understand it correctly you're quite
optimistic I think in one way about what
is actually going to happen in the end
and my question is about the available
alternatives that are out there and the
disintegration of the center-left in
Europe has been a feature since the
financial crisis I'm a member of the
Irish Labour Party myself which would
have been center-left for many years you
again if I pick up your point correctly
you talked about part of the solution
being the creation of a coalition
between the left and the center which we
would have and the social democratic
movement in Europe would have always
have seen themselves as among the
available alternatives out there who do
you see as best reflecting in Paris
political terms in Europe your your
philosophy good my role models in
politics are people like a de colo who
may today just be kicked out of the
mayor of being the mayor of Barcelona
what she's done she was a housing
activist been arrested became man she
she had two ruling coalition with the
Socialists so should be immediate not to
forget that the radical half of her
policies and she's no in trouble because
she didn't support Catalan independence
and she's probably going to be kicked
out by radical left catalysts so you
know what goes around comes around and
there are problems but addict allows did
this she said the data of the city is a
public good
so Cisco accentual all the contracts we
signed with you where you were going to
get the data in return for some shitty
wires and boxes no we're going to keep
the data and we're going to discuss
public common ownership models for the
further data by the way here's a local
assembly kaloud speaks to this size
meeting every day of local people and an
unlike state even great left politicians
like Corbin she actually listens to them
and she got your point yeah I come and
see you
there's that level of engagement and
they handed digital democracy to people
so anybody can suggest a law you need
30,000 signatures and then about 120,000
gets it gets the spending they allocated
spend to the to the internet decided
democracy I think that's the future
that's taking people I hope
you will win today and that is that and
I think my frustration with left
politics and of course centrist politics
is it remains at this at the emotionally
unintelligent level at the moment both
lots of it but we're all to blame and
we're all stuck in this if you lose an
election you see it tonight you have to
stand up and say well we win really
morally yes yeah you can't but you can't
base the narrative on lies and I'm
afraid a lot of politics is still at the
lion face Harriet
Arendt said a horrible ly true thing she
said when the Nazis said German society
can no longer guarantee your security
your prosperity they were lying the
truth that's what they did
and so so many of the demagogues who
will win tonight in Europe are lying the
truth that we we need a way of
guaranteeing security and prosperity for
everybody
otherwise the right will will convince
people that they can just a personal
question how you do feel you are
optimistic yeah three hundred three
hundred thousand years ago plus or minus
fifty thousand years we invented stone
tools okay or even beyond that we
there's a certain kind of stone tool
that begins then 10,000 12,000 years ago
pottery 2500 years ago
democracy 200 years ago steam engines
last year a silicon chip 4 nanometers
thick with the trillion switches on it
there's more switches in this room on
your mobile phone I would imagine that
the number of analog switches ever
created by electrical electrical
engineering in the world
3 billion each work it out that's how
many switches are on your phone the
machines in you have access to are
incredible though if you stand back and
look at that historic you know kind of
thing you say well they've got to do
something good these guys you know
they're they're motoring actually we're
also destroying the planet at the same
exponential rate if you look at the
cause drilled out of the Antarctic
you can see how exponentially bad the
climate situation is going to be but my
optimism is we can get into whether
there are technological fixes for
climate the fix for climate is human
behavior a mass transformation of human
behavior in 10 to 15 to
we can do it but the source of optimism
also lies in in what they observe about
the transformation of human beings those
who you know my work if you look at the
work work I've done around 2011 on the
networked individual you know I think
the the the the rising human capital of
the networked individual in in in the
democratic societies is something's very
hard to put back in a box
the sociologist Manuel Castells from
from Barcelona says you know you can't
dialect Rifai a country you can't do
Network a population so I'm optimistic
for that reason as far as I see your
view on future of technology you could
do as well on the context of bakunin as
one of marks a context of recruiting
yeah yeah I'm in a post-scarcity society
where we all have access to incredible
and powerful education why do you think
we need a group of elites to tell us
what way of living our life's is correct
I like to hear a strong and transparent
justification for the need of us of the
state in a post-scarcity society
property is theft well Luke there is no
justification for a state as we know it
in it in a society that has well almost
halfway to abundance level look let
alone complete court scarcity um I think
I am best known on the sort of radical
leg for saying that the state must be
the enabler of that transition that is
the capitalist bourgeois state that we
have with its institutions now so that
instead of building from the bottom up
with our coops and our nonprofit banks
and our ethical banks and credit unions
and organic collect collaborative farms
we need the state to do two things it
needs to clear a space for those
projects it not means suppressing
business models that don't fit with the
future outlawing some business models
like uber taxing offshore taxi tops your
money to bring capital and and providing
sources of capital to those businesses I
don't think you can do that without the
state and therefore one of the most
radical things you can do is just elect
a government that wants to do that
at the other end of it my vision is for
a hierarchy free and a state free
society so Mikhail Bakunin the the
Russian anarchist think is
you know I mean I'm a huge critic of
Marge there's more critique of Marx in
my book than there is of Pro Marx
there's also a chapter called reject the
thoughts of Xi Jinping we should go down
fantastically well in Beijing but not
that kind of State in other words but I
know I there is no justification for a
state but then you've got the real
question for me and it's more dealt with
in post capitalism to be honest is the
back half of that transition how do we
manage see I'm only paper over universal
basic income no provided by the state
but in order to to shrink the market
sector shrink the state sector of the
economy in order to allow a flourishing
non market non state sector a wiki
sector in that situation eventually the
money for the basic income runs out we
have to find non remunerative forms of
human interaction that provide services
I think we'll all production will be
automated and we need to learn how to
live a highly culturally conservative
consume culture and create culture I see
I see the billion pounds spent there by
the Arts Council triple that and you've
got you've got a huge motor for non
market production and consumption of
culture so that's the the near-term is a
kind of radical social democracy the far
term is what the people still live in
the back end of the 21st century want to
make it I won't be and and they'll have
to survive climate chaos if we get this
wrong finish on one thing the reader if
I'm right the real crunch comes in
persuading people governments and
institutions now today to do things that
seem wrong we need to borrow a lot of
money and use it to decarbonize the
economy we might have to print money to
pay for some of that borrowing so it
seems awful but you print the money you
buy the debt you bury it and the back
half of the 20th century 21st century
we'll have to deal with that but if we
don't do it they'll have to deal with
the sea being sort of up here in hey and
I'd much prefer the problems to be
fiscal and monetary problems than
drowning so thank you motivates talks
and interviews subscribe today
to the Institute's of Arts and ideas her
III TV
you